ich kann echt nichts dafür aber in der
wissenschaft gibt es halt echt fast
jeden tag unglaubliche nachrichten die
er ist und das ist die meinung eines
renommierten wissenschaftlers für zwei
nobelpreise gut es ist ein wirklich
wirklich unglaubliche blick die
entstehung unseres universums gelungen
und zwar genau in dem moment in dem
unser universum von einer trüben suppe
zu dem heutigen klaren fast vakuum wurde
und die ersten sterne entstanden und
dort entdeckte ein forschungsteam etwas
absolut verblüffendes eine
außergewöhnliche spur zur dunkle materie
alles über die beschwörer baden brechen
der entdeckung jetzt bei pixum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
es waren von 13,6 milliarden jahren 180
millionen jahre nach dem urknall
das größte spektakel unseres universums
damals stürzte die wasserstoff ursuppe
zu den ersten stern zusammen
sie zündeten und durch ihre
ultraviolette strahlung wird das sie
umgebende gas in heißes plasma
verwandelt diese plasma blasen
verschmelzen und langsam lichtet sich
das universum bis zum schluss nur noch
galaxien mit sternen planeten und
schwarzen löchern übrig sind genau an
diesem zeitpunkt der entstehung der
ersten sterne an diesem zeitpunkt zu
gucken das war bisher unmöglich so
dunkel war die wolke aus wasserstoff und
ein wenig helium doch dieses verborgene
geheimnis wurde jetzt gelüftet die
plasma blasen hinterließen ein eigenes
strahlungs muster und genau das wurde
jetzt gefunden bei einer wellenlänge von
21 zentimetern sorgten sie für eine
leicht erhöhte absorption der
hintergrundstrahlung doch diese leichte
strahlungs verringerung zu finden war
gar nicht so leicht zu sehr ist unsere
erdatmosphäre durch die menschlich
verursachten radiowellen verunreinigt
und auch in unserer galaxie gibt es noch
genügend störende strahlungsquellen all
das ist im radiowellenbereich 10.000 mal
lauter als die gesuchten signale zitat
es ist ein wenig so als säße man mitten
in einem harry kennt und würde versuchen
den flügelschlag eines kolibris zu hören
so peter kaczynski von der us national
science foundation
doch genau das ist gelungen zum einen
hat sich das forschungsteam nach
westaustralien zurückgezogen wo es
möglichst wenig vom menschen
verursachter radiowellen gibt und zum
anderen
haben sie ein vollkommen neues
messinstrument entwickelt ages das ist
ungefähr so groß wie eine
tischtennisplatte und imstande diese
veränderung der hintergrundstrahlung zu
messen und es ist gelungen zitat das
profil dieses signals ist konsistent mit
den erwartungen für das 21 zentimeter
signal der frühesten sterne die frequenz
entspricht der zeit von etwa 180
millionen jahre nach dem urknall so das
forschungsteam allerdings hat das team
etwas gefunden was sie so nicht erwartet
haben denn das was das plasma an
strahlung absorbiert hat das ist viel
mehr als vorher gesagt wurde und zwar
doppelt soviel zitat diese ergebnisse
erfordern einige veränderungen in
unseren vorstellungen von der frühen
entwicklung unseres universums was
könnte kosmologische modelle
beeinflussen und dazu führen dass die
theoretiker noch einmal darüber
nachdenken müssen wie dies zu erklären
ist sagt colin lonsdale vom haystack
observatoriums m
und jetzt kommt es könnte dunkler
materie für diese delle verantwortlich
sein
ein grund für die höhere absorption
könnte kälteres wasserstoffgas sein und
dafür könnte die dunkle materie
verantwortlich gewesen sein
zitat die einzige kosmische komponente
in die kelter sein kann als das früher
kosmische gast ist die dunkle materie so
rennern balkan von der universität tel
aviv das hätte ernsthafte konsequenzen
für die bisherigen modelle der dunkle
materie wimps könnten es dann nicht mehr
sein sie zeichnen sich ja gerade dadurch
aus dass sie mit normaler materie kaum
interagieren stattdessen könnten dann
eher aktionen oder sterile neutrinos für
die dunkle materie verantwortlich sein
zitat sollte sich diese hypothese
bestätigen dann hätten wir etwas neues
und grundlegendes über die mysteriöse
dunkle materie erfahren
das würde uns einen ersten blick auf
eine physik jenseits des standardmodells
liefern so der projektleiter dohmen von
der arizona state university es ist also
wirklich bahnbrechend was sie entdeckt
wurde
wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
dunkle materie zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert und ab
so gibt es dann auch besondere angebote
zum beispiel ein ort will gratis abo
also unbedingt anmelden
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der glocke vergessen
genau hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken sensationen dunkle materie
existiert wahrscheinlich nicht eine ganz
andere hypothese zur dunklen materie
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran